it's your first time on the show by
yourself for sure you were on last time
with the
Sada and that was a very entertaining
colorful conversation oh crazy we had
it's a lot of a lot of a lot of talk and
you were just in the corner like who the
[ __ ] are these old ass men
well welcome man it's good to see you
um
you've gotten a lot more icier since the
last time I saw you um explain the uh
tent with the Christmas tree necklace
what's going on here
yeah my friends we came up with
something we as a high school called
band camp so that's where the tent from
so is this like your crew your label or
it's my label am I I got a label called
we eat the most
and that's what my friends came up with
uh I ain't coming with that my friends
did I just wanna
I love my friends so [ __ ] I just wanna
if I can push the movement I'll push it
for real right that's dope man
um you've had a pretty active year in
terms of just like tons of Music being
dropped I know like everyone in their
mom's trying to sign you are you still
independent no I'm signing a guessing
through endoscope how long ago did the
Geffen thing happen like a month ago
well congratulations appreciate you
shout out to Geffen I know some good
Folks at Geffen well actually they just
left so they're not there anymore as of
like a week ago but shout out to Geffen
what made you go with Geffen
um it was more family oriented I know a
lot of people over there right and then
I know they threw Interscope and I know
a lot of people is with Interscope yeah
like Gaffin has had some uh some some
success stories like a dark [ __ ] got
uprooted or got Upstream today Broadway
when Alamo was over there that's dope
man the whole CMG over there at
Interscope yeah so there's still Griffin
and stuff so they even gotten people
like 50 Cent and Ice Cube like that at
Interscope still so well not interscopes
you know Interscope that's where
Eminem's at that's where Kendrick well
Kendrick was
and they yeah he's still kind of I was
like Hey Oh you know guessing through
endoscopes yeah I just felt like it was
a good move for me how crazy was like
the bidding war because was everybody in
Detroit is getting signed right now uh
so I know that like being one of the
hottest artists in the city you had to
have had maybe like your pick of the
litter in terms of like where you could
have went right yeah how crazy did I get
it was crazy it got so crazy to the
point where we got into arguments with
people like like people I ain't even
know like labels and stuff like that
like I had labels arguing like they they
did like the big one was crazy it
started at a number then it went up and
they went up like it's like an auction
for real I ain't never been a part of it
so I just sat back
but like my team like they was in
arguments and stuff like that
it's crazy I know you're a big sports
fan and it kind of feel like the closest
thing to like being a free agent and
being like recruited like you know we
were thinking like it was really like
draft like not even free agent it was
like me being in the draft I'm like oh
my God where I'm gonna go right like you
know it's just like because sometimes
you know how like it really was like the
college thing like
because I at a point I committed to
something and then I'm like do I really
like do I want to go there or do like am
I wrong but I don't know these people at
this point so I committed to these
people but I ain't it's not contractual
yet so it's like
my loyalty and me be like I committed to
something because that's how I was
raised like if I commit to something I'm
supposed to do that but business-wise if
it don't make sense I shouldn't do it so
it's like so did you commit to somebody
and then end up going to somewhere else
I end up I ended up committing to
somebody then
I end up
they was playing like they was they was
like the contracts weren't ready and all
this stuff
like I don't think there's plenty just
you know how the business stuff the
lawyer worked but I didn't know about
this at this point like I got lawyers
and stuff I never had like entertainment
lawyers and stuff so it's like contracts
weren't ready then somebody else came
and offered more and and pull it up on
me and made me feel like you know how
people be like they'll pull up on you
and make you want to change your mind
even though he pulled upon you was it
Gavin
gefin had already pulled up on me it was
really uh Jeff from uh he is over at
where he was at he's at Columbia now but
he was somewhere else so you just had
everyone yeah coming to Detroit
they didn't come see you I went to go
see people it was just like it was crazy
for real for real at a point in time it
was crazy to a point where I just
seeing the label didn't I'd be like damn
I want to go there then another label
like United Masters or something a DME
or Atlantic or something like that right
and it just it was crazy so obviously
shout out to SATA who's somebody who
helped you know you come up in the game
was was there any other artists like
because there's some artists with big
labels right you mentioned TMG there's
MMG there's I mean you can go on and on
did any other artists like try to come
in and like become a part of your
situation
no because I'm not really a I'm a people
person but I don't really let I don't
deal with like I deal well with people
but I don't really I'm standoffish right
so like
I like hanging with like the managers
and CEOs I don't really like hangover
artists because I feel like I can do the
same thing as you for real so and it's
like there's a few of those artists
though that are like you know like if I
be around them yeah it'd be like that
but it's like I already got my own money
I don't really need your money and then
to be like
everything on the internet or everybody
I stay away from artists because I've
been disappointed before like not by
like nobody that you see me with but
I've been disappointed with like meeting
people and they not like the same as I
thought they was going to be like
growing up like of course if I listen to
your music I damn there don't want to be
around you because
if I think like you're not like like I
don't it don't be I heard your screen
side it'd be like more of them [ __ ] like
yeah it'd be like you grew up being a
fan of somebody you meet them and
they're not a good person yeah like if
you're not a good person when I meet you
or you like an [ __ ] people and it'd
be like that'd be like bothering me so I
try to stay away from people the artists
who's somebody that you have met that
you were a fan of that did not
disappoint you Chris Brown Chris Brown G
herbo they were like real genuine G
herbo's the best they like it was real
genuine like
Chris Brown like you would think Chris
Brown to forget your name the next time
you see you he still know your name like
and like right this before anybody knew
I was trying to do music like I met
Chris Brown I was with shouting right
like and Chris Brown hop on that like
I [ __ ] with duck I ain't gonna lie did
you go with Sada when he met jelly roll
in in uh Detroit
jelly Rose my boy he does like country
and it was the most random [ __ ] ever I
like opened my story and I see Sada baby
like backstage with jelly roll I'm like
this is [ __ ] this is great it's like
the best of two different worlds coming
together I didn't know if you were with
him or not but